Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
and ahhh
just checking in on you.
Just checking in,
seeing how you're doing,
seeing how your week's going.
Right out of the bright out of the gate.
I got to plug something from my best friend in the world.
Paul Versey,
the pride of Trenton,
New Jersey.
Oh,
the fucking tulip in the garden at the garden state.
Paul Versey is going to be playing the Gotham Comedy Club in New York City this
Friday,
eight and 10:00 PM shows and this Saturday,
eight and 10:00 PM shows.
That's August 10th and August 11th.
Best friend in the world with the best club owners in the business.
The Mozillas,
the Mozillians brothers,
straight shooters.
My whole career,
they always gave it to me straight right from the very beginning.
Bill,
you're not funny.
Find another career.
Okay.
Stop bugging us for spots.
Always was straight shooters.
MMM.
You know what's funny is actually in Scarface,
they actually,
that's the first pass at,
at first cut of that movie,
uh,
he actually said the [inaudible] brothers.
Hey,
fucked up.
Fucking bacilli brothers,
right?
And then they're like,
Nah,
it's gotta sound.
It's got to sell some more Latino.
And as a bunch of white guys standing around and they were like,
ah,
DHEAS the about,
hey,
let's do it.
Fuck it.
Throw that in there.
Um,
speaking of things Latin that white people don't understand,
uh,
what the fuck is going on over at Taco Bell?
Can somebody explain to me how in such a sensitive day and age where people are
just,
you know,
having to apologize and,
and over any little fucking thing how they advertise on TV,
that they're bastardized version of Latin,
Latin,
probably the fuck you're supposed to say it.
Latino cuisine.
What is going,
what is that fucking incest you a shift that they keep,
but every time you think they can't get us one of their sandwiches to fuck
another sandwich and make a new sandwich,
they somehow do it.
They don't fucking pay first.
They just had tacos.
They had Burritos,
they had case studies,
which I didn't even know of case it is that they even have those in Mexico.
I don't know.
I'm just a white guy who grew up in white schools listening to white history.
Right.
They never took my entire time in school.
They never,
they didn't even bring up Mexico
and it was the Spanish American war.
They would bring up.
We thought it was in fucking Mexico and evidently it was in the South Pacific.
We didn't fucking know all they'd all I history every year started the same day.
It started with the fucking pilgrims coming over on the May flower,
the Nina,
the Pinta in the center of Maria and I don't know who may flower was.
Was that the,
the fucking Pete Best of the ships there?
Was that the Diana Ross?
I have no fucking idea.
All right.
And then there was that other guy,
uh,
Jones or some shit.
He say he settled down there in,
uh,
Virginia,
if I remember correctly.
He settled down in Virginia.
Right?
The fuck is going on with my mix it here,
I don't know.
And he started banging that a native American chick,
right?
He got a fucking Mohawk,
got some moccasins,
started using a bow and Arrow and then they said stay,
stay,
stay.
Tried to say that the native Americans killed them.
I guess cause they didn't like him banging on one of their women.
But you know,
I bet I actually think it might've been the white people.
They came over and they thought he was a sell out.
You're like,
hey dude,
how can we don't have a
buckle on your hat?
You know,
knocked on your gun isn't flaring out like Elmer Fudds at the end.
why is your girlfriend got such a wonderful,
beautiful tan there?
And then they took them out and then they blamed it on the native Americans.
And then they said that,
you know,
they were standing their ground and they wiped them out.
And then afterwards they all moved to Florida
and they fucked each other.
Incestuously just like the food at Taco Bell.
And that's why you now to this day have this stand your ground fucking bro.
You know,
I finally saw the footage of that latest stand your ground thing.
I just,
I don't fucking understand how anybody can't say that.
That's just fucking murder.
Second Degree fucking murder.
But I,
I,
you know,
you watch this guy will get acquitted.
Two things.
I'm always wrong on the stand.
Your ground footage and [inaudible] the,
did he or did he not make a football move?
I never get those right.
I'm like,
that's a fucking touchdown there.
After further review,
you know,
that's murder after further reveal,
the white guy was,
was
clearly felt threatened as the black guy was walking away
through this latest one,
right?
This,
this,
this guy,
right?
Black Dude with his wife or girlfriend.
I think there was a kid in the car.
Not sure,
right?
They pull in,
they parked in the handicapped spot.
So the white dude,
like the pussy that he is weights to,
the guy goes in the store and then starts yelling at this guy's girlfriend or
wife.
The guy comes walking out,
the guy's yelling at his wife.
So he goes over and he pushes him down like a big brother sticking up for his
little sister.
He pushed him down like they were on the playground.
And this fucking asshole
pulls out a gun,
like guy standing over him with an ax or something and the guy literally starts
to turn to walk away and he sees him take out the gun and he turns and looks
back at him like,
what the fuck?
And the guy shoots him in cold blood
Copeland.
I guarantee you he's going to get off.
He will get off
fucking unreal.
It's unreal.
But that's what happens.
That's what happens when you have a bunch of people fucking,
you know,
in the same puddle the way that they're doing with the food over there and Taco
Bell.
How do they get away with it?
All this shit about appropriating culture and everything and they just,
they just,
I don't know.
I think they've just gone so fuck.
It's like the island of Doctor Moreau meets Mexican food.
It's kind of like Hanna Barbera too,
where they just,
they,
they only had like two or three ideas.
If somehow they spun it into like 40 different cartoons.
All right.
We got an idea for a cartoon.
You ever seen the honeymooners?
Yeah.
It's that,
except it's in the stone age.
It's called the Flinstones.
Oh,
we love it.
We love it.
You got any more ideas?
Yeah.
You know the honeymooners that we stuck in the stone age and was the Flinstones.
Now we'll stick it in the future.
It's called the Jetsons.
Oh yeah.
You got any more shows?
I add.
It's a fucking,
uh,
is a bear.
I Dunno.
Then this one is,
was a lion.
They're all the animals.
This one's a fucking a,
there's always going to be one tall,
one in one short one.
I think the high watermark was jinxed the cat.
All right.
Um,
I like chinks.
The cash.
He was,
he was really,
he was,
he was fucking cool.
Hey,
uh,
like a,
what'd she scram Outta here?
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I literally doing a jinx.
The cat impression.
Well,
what do,
what do you want from me?
Huh?
What do you want from me up?
Just a white guy,
man.
All the doors swing wide open for me.
Um,
I watched an episode of Mannix the other day.
I'm loving me TV.
I'm loving it.
You know,
it's just TV shows.
There's commercials,
there's a schedule.
It's how I used to watch TV.
Okay.
There's,
there's auto shape or white guys chasing down people half their age,
rolling over hoods of cars.
It's just like,
yeah,
there's a live band that played the soundtrack.
I mean,
it's just,
it's,
I'm,
I'm doing,
what I shouldn't be doing right now is I'm,
I'm turning the wagon around and I'm going back to where I fucking was and I
will quickly become irrelevant,
but I,
I can't,
I can't lay off BTBY.
I watched this episode of Mannix,
right?
He drives a dodge dart,
like the fucking
gt version of some shit.
I didn't,
I never even heard of that car.
You always had to have the cool car.
Right?
He's alone or he's not married.
They're always loan as though he's not married.
That way they can get laid in every fucking,
every show.
It's totally this,
the show is just totally designed for unhappily married guys.
Right?
Like,
why did I get married?
I should've stayed single and fucking solve crime,
drive it around in a cool car and just fucking banging somebody different 34
times a year.
That's basically how many episodes that did,
right.
So I'm watching Mannix,
and it's this episode where this is Hitman in a fucking phone booth,
and he's talking about a murder he just committed.
And this woman staring at him,
then she starts staring at his lips and shit,
right?
And I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
Right?
It turns out she's deaf.
What she steps are easy joke.
MMM.
Okay.
So she knows what's up.
So they go to the cops,
the cops don't land.
What's the guy look like?
What?
Get Out of here?
You Deaf Lady,
right?
They don't listen to her,
but man,
x happens to be walking by.
He's a private eye.
I don't know what he's doing down at the fucking,
at the police station.
Maybe he's down there fucking,
you know,
trying to get some work,
get a couple of fucking free donuts and coffee.
I don't know why he's down there,
but he was down there.
He was fucking down there.
Right.
So,
um,
he just wanted,
he sees them yelling at deaf chicken.
He sits like,
hey man,
you know,
uh,
that's an interesting story.
I think I can help you out with that.
You know,
cause she was like so surprised that she sought you so upset she couldn't really
give them any details.
So man x,
because he's Mannix,
because he's a loner because he has no woman in his life that he has to answer
to.
He actually has the fucking time spur of the moment to take on this fucking
case.
Right.
And what's funny is I just like,
who the fuck was paying them the whole episode he did the,
he did it.
Was it pro bono?
Was that free?
Is that the right expression?
You know,
they were going down to report a fucking crime.
They weren't saying,
Hey,
help solve this fucking crime.
He takes it on.
So they cut to the next scene and he's still,
the deaf woman is freaking out because Maddox is yelling at her,
go,
come on.
You got to remember,
we got to go through this again.
Right.
And her friend is going,
Jesus Christ,
dude,
take it easy.
He goes there,
there's a woman's life at stake.
And the definitely,
she's fucking holding her head and shit.
They basically just verbally abuses her until she can fucking remember what this
guy looks like.
And,
uh,
and it kind of goes from there.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I don't even want
him talking about this shit.
I'm just saying,
you got to watch me TV.
It's fucking tremendous.
It's fucking Fermentis especially,
you know,
you go on all these other shows and it's like 2018 and then you just turn the
fucking channel and it goes back to,
I,
I swear to God,
the way they treated women back then,
the parts that they gave him,
the way that they talk to them,
their idea,
like
what do the women would walk in and they were nothing but sex objects.
Every fucking woman right comes in and they just start playing a saxophone.
Trying to think what they played for the deaf woman.
You probably played like a muted trumpet or something,
but still they played it in a sexy way.
Um,
I don't want to talk about,
but how about those Red Sox?
Everybody dropping 20 runs 10 at night on a Toronto Blue Jays.
Hey Getty.
Lee,
you're liking that Shit,
Huh?
I'll never forgive that guy.
I remember reading an interview when he was at a blue jays game and he was
fucking make it fun of Red Sox fans.
They were up there,
you know,
I'll never forget that.
I was just like,
oh,
okay gay.
That's how you want to play it.
Huh?
With your fucking 12 string bass guitar and your songs about space or whatever
the fuck you talking about up there.
MMM.
Honestly I have legit
like a sports disliked.
Not,
not,
not an honest dislike,
you know,
but if I ever met the guy,
I would definitely bring it up.
Um,
because I am a,
I'm childless anyways.
Red Sox keep winning.
Yankee suggest one to,
you know,
all the Yankee fans had their fucking head in the oven.
Then all of a sudden what happens to get a new picture?
He goes up,
he strikes fucking everybody out and then the next night she,
the guy you,
you bought from the fucking Marlin's.
Yeah.
Goes opposite field for a grand slam.
I was checking out our fucking schedule,
man.
I can't wait.
I cannot wait for that fucking astro series.
I can't believe how excited I am about baseball.
I don't know what happened.
I,
I given up on the,
I know what happened.
All the fucking steroids I gave up on.
I was just like,
look,
either legalize them or get them out of the gate.
Stop having me get excited for shit that you're going to then tell me a fucking
five years later that it didn't really count.
You know,
um,
anyone's excited state Indian series.
Oh,
I can't wait.
And to sit here and be this far ahead of the Yankees knowing that it means
absolutely nothing because of the wild card.
It's just,
it's just such a wonderful feeling,
you know,
knowing that you're counting down days that mean nothing.
What's your magic number?
Uh,
17 more games plus four games in the playoffs.
They ruin it.
Fucking greedy cuts ruined it.
MMM.
You know,
back in the day,
I've told you this before,
if you had the best record in the American league that was winning the pennant,
there was no playoffs to win the pennant.
It was the regular season.
And then you immediately went to the world series.
So what you had to do was you had had the best record and they,
and all they had was like,
there wasn't division,
so it was just a,
you know,
like eight teams in this division,
eight teams in that division of what and that,
uh,
sorry,
not division.
Um,
in that league,
like eight teams in the American League,
eight teams in the National League and whoever the top guys were at the end of
the season,
you,
you won the pennant,
you went to the world series.
So that's why like,
no one's ever gonna win the way the Yankees won way back then.
First of all,
there's no way you're gonna,
you're gonna fucking,
someone's going to be dumb enough to sell your babe Ruth then.
Then you're going to draft Lou Gehrig,
Mickey Mantle,
a Joe Dimaggio right in a fucking row.
Um,
and then you go to the playoffs.
You only have to wait for games and you got the fucking title.
You know what I mean?
But,
eh,
but I'm not just shitting on the Yankees.
Cause I know like,
uh,
back in the day,
um,
in hockey,
all you had to do is you had to win eight,
get yet went to playoff series.
Now you have to win twice as many.
I'm sure when the Celtics were winning all of theirs,
I can't imagine you had to play any more than one or two rounds of 'em.
Oh,
I'll play offs.
Right.
Play offs.
That's actually interesting.
Let me see.
Night
team 50 ml be steady.
The standings,
this stair dings.
All right,
so here it was.
All right.
1950 there was one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight.
Just like a guest.
All right.
The Yankees,
of course one that won the pennant,
one had the best record,
won the pennant tigers for three games back.
Red Sox were for the Indians were six and that's the top four.
And then the bottom for this works out mathematically cause you didn't have
inner league play.
The twins were 31 games out the white sox for 38.
The Orioles were 40.
And the probably Philadelphia athletics at that time.
We're,
uh,
46 games up.
If not,
maybe they were in Kansas City at that point,
and then,
and the national league,
the Phillies were in first place,
then the Dodgers than the giants.
Then the Braves,
cardinals,
the reds,
the cubs and the pirates.
That's it.
So then the Phillies and the Yankees played for the world series and we all know
fucking one that right.
All right,
let's go 1962
and be a stair day.
The NBA standings.
All right.
What do we got here?
Yeah,
there was,
they call them divisions.
There was western divisions.
There was nineteens.
So the Lakers,
well they Minneapolis then I think.
No,
they,
they moved to la by that.
Then there was the kings who I believe back then where the
Rochester royals
that became the Cincinnati royals
and then they became the Sacramento Kings,
I think.
What are the royals become?
The San Diego Clippers that became the La Clippers.
I always forget that.
Anyways,
Detroit Pistons,
Atlanta hop St Louis Hawks.
Sorry.
They might've been in Atlanta at that point.
And then the Washington Wizards,
which will do look bullets.
That's weird.
They run that long.
I had no idea.
And then in the eastern division,
it was the Celtics,
uh,
the San Francisco Warriors,
the 70 sixers in the next 31 games out.
Um,
yeah.
So that's it.
So you just,
yeah,
I guess you just won and then you played for,
for games to see who was the champion?
Steph,
that's something that people don't fucking bring up a lot.
They always go,
oh,
it was a bunch of fucking white guys on the YMC a fair enough.
Fair enough.
But also you didn't have to win 20 rounds of the fucking playoffs.
And the only reason why they have all these rounds now is,
uh,
well mostly for money.
But you know,
in all fairness,
when there's only nine fucking teams,
I mean,
do you really need to also make the playoffs if he came in second?
MMM.
I know they just kind of made a lot of the regular season null and void in a lot
of these sports.
Why am I not getting any fucking volume here?
I just seen it.
I hope this isn't too quiet again.
You know,
I think I'm going to have to break down and actually get a goddamn producer on
this fucking thing,
you know?
And then what do I do then when I do and I get somebody else I've got to fucking
talk to.
That's not what I want to do.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's back up here.
All right,
let's read a little advertising hymns.
Everybody.
Here's a problem.
66% of men lose their hair by age 35.
Hey man,
that's offensive
thing is when you start to notice hair loss,
it's too late.
Uh,
well shit,
where the fuck was that when I needed it?
Easy.
It's easier to keep the hair you have than to replace the hair you've lost.
Is that hairline slowly starting to move backwards,
backwards.
Any bald spots yet?
How will you feel a year from now if it's business as usual up there?
Why do you guys turn to weird solutions or do nothing when they can turn to
medicine and science?
You know,
I'm real.
What do you,
what do you mean weird solutions?
Like what?
Just fucking aging naturally shaving your head and all of a sudden everybody
thinks you know Jujitsu or possibly you have a fatal disease,
right?
Either way,
you know people are clearing a path.
What hymns does is connect you with real doctors and medical grade solutions to
treat hair loss,
well known generic equivalents to name brand prescriptions that help you keep
your hair.
No snake oil pills or gas station,
counter supplements.
Prescription solutions backed by science.
No waiting room,
no awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going to four hymns for h I m s for him.
Is that.com answer a few quick questions.
Dr.
Review and prescribe you products or shipping or shipped directly to your
doctor.
I always feel like those guys when they ask questions about hair loss is the
first thing asks how much hair is on your back
so they can guess how quickly you're going to lose your hair.
Cause those hairy motherfuckers,
they lose it.
Like you know those kids who can grow a beard and like fucking junior high the
second puberty's ended all of a sudden.
Yeah.
You know,
they start looking like,
like,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Pick somebody.
Pick somebody that Bill Murray or something.
All right,
order.
Now my listeners get a trial month of him of hymns for just $5 today.
Right now while supplies last.
See websites for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to the doctor rather pharmacy,
go to him.
[inaudible] dot com slash bird that's for h I m
s.com/burr for him,
[inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] for [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible]
all right.
What's your box?
Hey,
I fucked up when I say that you get free bacon for life.
You get free bacon the first time.
That was that.
That was a tight vote.
That wasn't my fault.
Somebody fucked that up.
All right.
What's your box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free
range,
organic chicken and heritage bread.
Pork.
The greatest pork chop I've ever had.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones.
Each box comes with at least nine to 11 pounds of meat with which is enough for
24 individual sizes unless you're a fat bastard.
Then you got three meals you can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
Custom box lets you choose your own cuts.
All right,
so the conservative guy is going to get all beef right?
The liberal out here in Hollywood's going to get a mixed box,
anti biotic slash hormone free books.
Your box believes in hell I healthier food system where everyone has access to
meets the way nature intended,
free of antibiotics and hormones and humanely raised on an open pasture before
they kill them.
Selection butcher box carefully curated the finest selection and cuts and makes
it a breeze to customize your own delivery.
Build your own box to get exactly what you and your family love.
Choose your delivery frequency with the customizable subscription with a cost.
With the customizable subscription,
sorry.
Recipes are available on the butcher box.
Websites and videos are available to follow along on butcher box youtube channel
to receive free bacon for the,
with the first order plus $10 off your order.
Go to butcher box.com.
Click on the big bank in banner on the homepage and use Berbee.
You are are at checkout.
Go now.
Limited time offer.
Oh,
Postmates everybody.
Postmates,
Postmates when you want food but don't want to get up your ass.
There's Postmates,
they're eating your fries.
Um,
as usual,
your stomach and the rest of your life are at war.
You need to eat,
but you can't stop what you're doing to deal with it.
And the only fast things that deliver are not what you want.
Introducing Postmates,
the APP that adds a delivery.
Option two,
your favorite restaurants.
I actually use this shit.
It's fucking great.
Especially when you want to eat healthy because a lot of times the healthy
restaurants don't deliver the Postmates got them,
but they'll go down and pick it up for you.
Bring it over to you.
Next morning you wake up,
you stomach's a little flatter.
Thank you.
Postmates.
Imagine anything you want to eat,
delivered.
Anything.
Yeah.
You don't have to drive,
park or even talk on the phone to order.
Just download the APP in order to 24 hours a day,
365 days a year.
Postmates will bring you what you want within the hour.
You can even see where your food is and track your driver.
You forget you forgot to get eggs and milk.
No problem.
Craven,
a tasty Burger.
We got you looking for a book,
the perfect bottle of red wine or summer bare order up.
Postmates is you knew longterm munchies booty call.
I liked that they get the weak people and the drunks all at the same time in
that sentence,
Huh?
For a limited time,
Postmates has giving you $100 of free delivery credit for your first seven days
to stat your free deliveries.
Download the APP today and use the Code [inaudible] 100 B U r r 100 that's code
for 100 but $100 of free delivery credit for your first seven days.
They save the hassle.
Get the food you love fast that Postmates with code burb 100 all right.
Lastly,
but not leastly.
Oh Geez.
Is Dollar Shave Club everybody?
Do you got stubble on your nuts that you want to get rid of without taking them
off?
Dollar Shave Club delivers everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best dollar shave club,
everything he has,
everything that you need to get ready in the bathroom.
Any particular product that yeah,
have fallen in love with outside of the razor and why?
I guess that's for me,
right?
I'm allegedly getting the one wipe Charlie's dollar shave club.
Yes.
That's dollar shave club delivers everything.
Yeah.
Need to look,
feel and smell your best.
You name,
Oh yeah.
Name Shampoo,
conditioner,
body wash,
toothpaste,
Hair Gel.
Even a wipe that Alivia Tush.
Elon typically clean there.
Evidently according to the copy,
I am a big fan of their amber and lavender calming body cleanser.
I want to use that.
Put a red on my fucking head.
Never smelled anything like it for just five bucks young can get their daily
essential status set.
It comes with the body cleanser one way.
Cherry,
they're amazing,
but whites,
they're world famous shave butter and their best razor.
The six blade executive.
Sure.
You're wondering why.
I'll ask you to be here today.
Keep the blades coming for a couple of bucks more a month and add in shampoo,
toothpaste,
or anything else you need for the bathroom.
Check it all out@dollarshaveclub.com slash [inaudible] that's dollar shave
club.com/burr.
All right.
Did I talk about everything I wanted to talk about?
Um,
I think that's it.
Football season,
starting up.
Oh,
you know what I've got,
I always in the morning,
my job is,
I get,
I get my daughter out of bed,
right?
You've got a whole little ritual I carry over.
I let her turn on the light,
you know,
but it turn off the light when we leave the room and all of that stuff.
And then whenever I bring up,
my wife always stays in bed.
You know what I mean?
I'm,
I'm really learning.
I'm learning how to,
how to get along.
I'm telling you it's,
it's actually,
it's not that hard to get along with your class.
This is what you gotta do all right in the morning.
It just snuggle up behind him.
I know this is Sally's going to be weird and all you do just caress him a little
bit.
Five minutes.
You do that five fucking minutes,
right?
The second you start doing it,
they go,
oh,
and you just fucking do that.
Keeps him in a good mood.
All right?
But you,
you know,
stocks that that'll get,
that'll give you peace until about 11:00 AM plus if you get up and you make the
breakfast in your feed your kid,
right?
You sitting there like fucking,
I always feel like Joe Pesci in casino.
You know,
cause I'm sitting here being a sweetheart,
I'm totally calm,
relaxed,
you know,
totally enamored with my beautiful daughter,
right?
And I,
and I've been in my head,
I'm like,
I'm a piece of shit,
right?
So I always,
I always have like that fucking,
I'm a lunatic,
right?
So anyways,
but here's the thing though,
and this isn't just a woman that just people in general,
they get used to ship.
So you can't do it every day,
all right?
But you got to do some version of that,
okay?
Just to,
just to fucking,
you know,
they're like rescue dog.
She just,
you want to keep them calm.
You want to keep the ears down,
keep the fucking ears down.
All right.
You're going to be good until about 11 in the morning.
And I ran around 11 in the morning.
They,
they're starting to read that text.
They got a couple of phone calls that can get crazy.
So your job is,
you have to get out of the fucking house before that happens.
Okay.
And this is another thing that I learned.
When they're bitching,
just shut the fuck up and listen.
Every once in a while you have to make a noise or else then they get weirded out
religious be like,
oh,
I feel like I just like staring at me and judging big.
And then you got to keep your voice down.
Yeah.
You can't be like a fucking listen to you.
You can't do that.
Cause then it's a fight.
You know you're going to want to do that because for the last 42 minutes you had
the solution.
You had the logical solution to whatever the fuck they were talking about,
but you can't,
you know that that was the old man.
I would just break eight seconds in.
I would just be gone.
Well then don't be friends with her.
Don't be,
tell her to fuck off.
Yeah.
Just stop hanging out with her and,
and you just can't do that.
You just have to fucking,
you just have to sit there.
You know what Song I,
you know,
when the,
when they're in one of those things where they're just going to go for 40
fucking minutes
is I just think of that white stripes song,
uh,
flat
Paradis Udall,
and I just had that fucking playing in a loop in my head.
Not even the part where he sings.
It's just the guitar.
Well,
Jane
[inaudible],
it's like haunting and calming all at the same fucking time.
And every once in a while I just go like,
wow,
that's,
that's terrible.
Then what happened?
And you just,
you just fucking stay in the pocket.
You can do that.
I'm telling you,
you're going to immediately,
40% of your fights are gonna go out the fucking window.
Now that other 60%,
I don't know how much I can whittle that down,
but I am telling you guys right now,
I am 40% happier just doing that.
Yeah,
rescue dogs.
Remember that?
You know you have no idea what the fuck happened to him before you got it.
Okay.
So you've got to figure out what the fuck makes them tick.
Cause if you don't,
they're going to be,
they're going to be on your neck.
Thank you guys so much for listening and as I want to especially thank anybody
who took anything I said on this podcast.
Seriously,
um,
have a great weekend yet.
Cons and I'll fucking check in on,
you know,
I'll,
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Um,
Oh,
you know what?
I talked to [inaudible] who is going to be headlining the Gotham property down
there and fucking go see a guy who's played every fucking room you had to,
to get that Goddamn Gig.
The guy who didn't need it,
he didn't take any fucking shortcuts or yarn.
Nay.
Go down there
it go.
See my buddy.
Do some comedy.
All right.
If you can't,
I would appreciate it.
All right,
and Ah,
that's it.
Oh,
I think the giants have their first preseason game tonight.
I also heard that football's back at the boys a back gate down.
Yeah.
All right.
Listen to the music and enjoy a a bonus half hour on a Thursday afternoon just
before Friday,
Monday morning podcast,
a classic episode from a Thursday from a,
I don't know,
years ago or maybe a couple of weeks ago.
I don't know.
I don't know how it works.
See you on Monday.
Market share.
Got,
Gosh,
she was Sharon,
Sharon,
Alex on the topic like he had a scar and Bobby was,
they were all in love with Diane.
They were doing it in Texas.
Tommy plays,
he had like a kid out in the writing of any logs like in Dallas.
He was dancing with the train.
They were all slept with guy and they were drinking from a fountain.
That was more in like
the last coming down from the mountains.
I don't
buy
[inaudible]
Mike flight
from Los Angeles into Logan Airport.
Everything's going,
everything's going fine,
right?
We take off from a lax.
Yeah.
When you look down to the left,
you see that little fucking barrier where Marine Del Rey is where Bravo airspace
is.
You know where the helicopters go?
150 feet off the fucking surface to transition the bravo airspace.
We're fucking up and over those countries.
We Bang a left.
We're climbing up.
You know,
going back over Hollywood was so high up.
I can see over the Hollywood hills.
I can see into the valley.
You know,
I saw that Ucla campus.
Then you see a la Colosseum when right over the fucking Rosebowl and then right
off into the Mojave desert flew right over Vegas.
I looked down,
I saw this stratosphere,
right?
Then you're in the Utah.
You go over the continental divide,
the fucking rocky mountains,
and then we out.
We're out of the great plagues,
the food supply.
Everybody,
that's where they poison it right there from the halls are Martez.
Oh my God.
Bless America.
Right?
Flying Right over our food supply that for some reason,
some reason we're letting these countries poison it,
right?
Some reason we're going after the terrorist over there,
but the fucking wants in the suits.
Soviets.
Okay.
So Kay spray the big casino all over it.
Keep the bugs off it.
Fantastic.
Ah,
just rented under the Faucet.
You'll be fine anyways.
Hey,
feed that cow some more cow.
MMM.
Cut The beaks off of them.
So you fly over that shit right then.
I don't know.
By then the sun started going down and everything was fine.
And uh,
you know,
I was working on writing some stuff and a shooting the shit with this guy and I
was telling me he's got this room,
he has a,
he's got a garage right?
With a room over it,
which is my dream fucking house,
man.
I always wanted to have an old house with a detached garage with a rum over.
I already told you this shit.
I turned the upstairs into a drum room slash cigar bar slash hooker lounge slash
sports bar like every man wants,
right?
MMM.
So he basically had that minus the hookers,
minuses to God by minus the drums,
whatever he had.
It's his fucking you pool table and all that shit.
So we're just having a great time.
Just a good guy shooting the shit with,
he wasn't coughing,
he didn't seem like he had a bowler was a nice time.
So all of a sudden we,
we started our initial offense,
the to the Boston area and um,
we're out over the fucking wall,
you know,
and all of a sudden we were just doing like this circular pattern.
I think we went north of the city up by Newbury port in Marblehead and we're
just doing like this fucking circle and we go round and we go around again and
I'm thinking,
uh,
this is a holding pattern there.
Seems really low.
And uh,
the guy comes on and he's like,
dad,
we haven't a little mechanical issue literally and tried to get it out in a lie
on the ground shortly.
But I love that we're having,
we're having a mechanical problem.
Uh,
but we expect to be on the ground shortly.
That can be taken two different ways.
Either we're going to fix it and I'll be able to land this fucker or it's going
to be a catastrophic failure of something,
at which point gravity is going to take over and land this plane for us.
Right,
right.
To somebody back deck there.
Um,
so long story short,
um,
I wasn't even paying attention.
That's the weird part.
I wasn't nervous at all,
which was another weird thing.
So,
uh,
he comes on the fucking thing and he would go in for the landing and he said,
ah,
okay,
we're gonna begin our initial descent to a final whatever,
blah,
blah blah at Logan airport.
Uh,
just to let you know,
there's gotta be some emergency vehicles on the runway.
There's nothing to be concerned about.
This is just standard procedure.
Buh,
Buh Buh.
It's like,
what the fuck you mean is to see that would be nervous about the brought up the
fire trucks.
I know what this is for.
This is in case we're all covered in jet fuel in eight minutes and we're on
fire.
At which point you can't really save any of us.
You just preventing this airplane from burning down the rest of the airport as
we cartwheel down the fucking runway.
So anyways,
long story short,
there was a flap that was stuck.
Um,
somebody said it was stuck up,
but we had to land faster than normal.
So I don't think it was able,
I don't think it was moving,
you know,
don't you go flaps down or whatever to slow the fucking thing down when you go
to land.
Isn't that what all these years of flying?
I believe that that's what happens.
Um,
what,
what have we had to land faster than a,
probably what you're supposed to probably outside the envelope is the pilot say
landed.
Not,
it didn't even land that hard,
you know,
and everybody in the back applauds.
Nobody in FirstClass applauds,
you know,
cause they don't have any Sol's,
uh,
including myself,
you know,
and as we land and,
uh,
we pull over whatever and it was,
it was pretty fucking awesome,
pretty awesome feeling knowing that the guy was that good.
But he basically just
prevented us all from dying.
I guess.
They all do it every time they landed safely.
But,
uh,
to be able to kind of handle that,
I just can't imagine being that pilot up there.
You only like comforting feeling I would have,
which you,
you'd have more concerned for the people in the back then you did for yourself
so you can kind of stay relaxed and just be thinking,
I have to keep my wits so I don't kill these other people.
But other than that,
what if,
what a responsibility can you imagine that if I fuck this up,
I'm going to kill 350 people,
you know?
And then even worse,
whenever you know,
a plane goes down,
they examine it.
And if it comes down to being like,
even though that was a mechanical situation,
you know,
at some point they tried,
they put it on the pilot,
insurance companies see,
you know what it was Chucky's fought da fuck,
he wore the wrong kind of shoes and I use pushing too far.
Right,
right,
right.
They'd figure out something that somehow to blame it on the pilot,
you know,
so they can kind of keep the lawsuits.
Yeah.
At a minimum.
I don't know.
I W I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
So whatever,
um,
this guy landed us there safely.
Thank fucking Christ.
And,
uh,
so I've been back here in my hometown for the last,
since Friday and I've been,
I've been pretty good.
I have not,
uh,
I have not hit one of my old,
eating haunts cause I put on a little bit of fucking weight there I was,
I was sitting in the Writers' room writingF is for family or are pitching jokes
as the writers write it.
And um,
you know,
you know the deal.
I get like five,
10 outside the fucking zone and I f I stand in the mirror and I felt shamed
myself.
I give myself a little fucking halftime speech,
you know,
what the fuck was that today?
Yeah.
It out.
And then I,
I can I get myself back on the stick?
So,
uh,
I'm telling you all this shit that I say,
despite the fact that I don't know why I didn't know anything about nutrition or
I know very little.
I'm telling you my tricks fucking work.
When you just can't stop yourself.
And you know you've got,
you want to eat a large pizza and you fucking know it and you know you
shouldn't,
you're actually stepping outside the craving,
you know,
to be like,
dude,
what the fuck are you doing?
Do not shove that fucking wheel his shit down your throat.
Walk away.
All right,
drop the fork and walk away.
Right?
You know it,
you know what you're supposed to do.
But you kicked that,
that craving,
that sugar,
salt,
fucking craving it just having you.
It's like you're not even controlling your body.
You walk over there,
that's when you just have to fucking override it with common sense in order of
fucking salad as quickly as possible.
Shove that down your fucking throat and immediately,
not immediately take about five minutes,
you levels,
whatever that is,
that craving levels off cause you full fills you up and then you look at that
page and you go,
what the fuck was I thinking?
Why the hell would I ever do that?
So I did that to myself.
I made a game plan before we even left.
Um,
I went to the airport and they had one place you could actually get a salad
right on.
I fucking shove that down my throat before I got on the plane.
And then I got on the plane and then I was fine and I had a banana for the
flight,
shove that down my throat.
I kept pounding the waters to keep the stomach full.
And at one point I had to give in.
I bought,
I got a fucking whiskey and uh,
and then that was it.
I was like,
all right,
did a great fucking job.
And then all of a sudden the plane broke and I was like,
God,
fuck,
I should've got the Sunday.
But is it too late to order some fog?
Uh,
keep the drinks come in their suite at,
um,
have we ended up fucking landing safely and uh,
I'm back on the stick.
Diane fiery auto crashes.
Some will die and hopper three while sift things through my ashes self will fall
in love of life and drinking from a fountain that is boring.
Like an avalanche coming down the mountain.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August 9th,
2010.
How the hell are you?
Are you doing good?
Are you feeling okay?
Um,
I actually tried to do this podcast last night and I was just too fucking beat
from doing the road,
but uh,
believe it or not,
I had one of my best road gigs of all time.
I worked the comedy store down in La Jolla,
California,
La Jolla,
La j o l l a I think.
I Dunno for all you fucking Caucasians out there.
Hey,
I'll come at eight fucking Lajolla.
Lajolla okay.
No one of the got such difficult time assimilating and you know how to fucking
spell
La Jolla is la fuck and h ow fucking want.
Hey Buddy.
Um,
La Jolla,
California.
And I performed down at the comedy store and I had a tremendous time.
I stayed down at a hotel right down on Pacific beach,
underrated Pacific beach.
I had a great time.
Evidently I heard late at night though.
The kids can get a little bit rowdy,
but that's what kids do.
They don't know how to get pussy.
They don't,
they're young.
So what do they do?
Walk around with their chest puffed out.
They can,
that's going to make some broad come over and touch it.
And then when she doesn't,
you start drinking more,
right?
And then you see somebody who is getting,
and then what do you do?
A,
you take off your buttoned down.
He got your stupid fucking tank top on.
Oh,
little bit of the folk of muscles over [inaudible] and then next thing you know
there's a fight.
Is that how it goes down,
Bill?
I have no idea.
Tell went down in the fucking eighties,
you know,
everybody had their feathered mullets,
you know they have Bobby Brown steel toed dance shoes.
You know,
back when Bobby Brown was fucking Bobbi Brown,
Mark Walberg had just started lifting weights,
talk in the 80s,
talking the fucking eighties.
Um,
yeah,
I had an unbelievable time this weekend,
this week after two weeks of alcohol abuse.
I'm actually sitting here drinking a smoothie like a fag and I'm loving every
second of it.
I'll tell you,
it's two days down on the beach.
I'm just like,
I get it.
I totally get it.
This whole east coast angry,
you know,
spend your life,
your teeth.
Grit,
holding her fucking shovel,
waiting for the next nor'easter.
It's just not the way to live
was fucking people down there in La Jolla.
Lajolla whenever the fuck you want to call it,
they,
they have life down.
Everybody inside down there was in great shape.
You know,
people riding bikes,
people still rollerblading,
jogging,
doing yoga.
Sun was shining.
So I went out and got a smoothie.
He said,
fuck it.
You know,
when in Rome,
but on some yoga,
stretchy pants and some flip flops.
And I didn't do that.
I didn't take it that far.
But uh,
yeah,
I was talking to a buddy of mine down there and he was explaining to me why,
uh,
why sound like a fucking,
well,
why should you worry?
What's wrong with that?
Um,
he was telling me why.
Uh,
starting off with juice was a good thing.
Kind of equated it to do an engine.
You know,
you go out,
you let your car fucking warm up first before you drive a hundred miles an hour
down the street.
Don't you.
So rather than take it one of those fucking Goddamn breakfast sandwiches,
that'll be the death yet,
you know,
having some Nag and broaden your life and you compound that,
compile it,
something with the sea.
That means in addition,
um,
you have a breakfast sandwich with the bacon or the sausage,
which form of dead pig do you want on this fucking thing,
you know,
that'll kill you.
So less like three,
four days.
I've been drinking the smoothie to start off the damn day and I'm feeling great.
And I know right now all you guys are going to fucking go onto the EMM podcast
and continue your fucking threads about what a pussy on becoming.
And I gotta be honest with you,
I don't give a shit,
you know,
I'm like that fucking astronaut who just thinks spaces beauty,
beautiful.
And I just let go of the ship and everybody else is sitting there and horror,
you know,
is I just sort of float away with that stupid smile on my face.
At least he floated away doing what he loved.
Yeah.
That's where I'm gone.
I've got a lot of shit last week on my alleged fan.
You know,
only I would get trashed on my,
my,
my alleged fan page,
the [inaudible] podcast.com if you haven't visited there,
uh,
you're missing out because that's where all the cool kids are,
you know,
with the jeans rolled up,
listen to at the hop.
Um,
no,
I,
I recommend youtube videos and all that shit when rather than having to go on
and search them yourself,
you can actually just,
we do it for you at the m podcast.
It's sort of a mom and pop store with no mother or no father.
It's a tragic story and I'm not going to get into it.
But anyways,
I got trashed on my own alleged fan page about my,
uh,
my alcohol tolerance because last week I was hung over because the night before
he had two whiskeys and to Miller high life and uh,
everybody was spear basically,
you know,
doing what people,
that's all you would do.
Or I can fucking drink a fucking case and you know,
go unload a fucking truck soak in.
I,
when I was in my twenties it's called being 42 people.
Do you think I'm proud of that shit?
This is the deal.
If I have one beer,
just one beer late at night,
I wake up the next day.
If I didn't drink a tall glass of water,
I feel the effects.
All right.
I'm like,
it's fucking 14 year NFL vet.
That's what my livers like.
My liver is like the entire late seventies Pittsburgh Steelers brains right now.
What's really fucking bed,
whatever.
Um,
if I,
I can't handle it the way I used to.
All right.
You know,
what did evil Knievel due at the end of his fucking life?
Was he still jumping off of shit or is he fucking lane in agony?
Slumped over.
A fucking Ottoman.
I mean,
you ask yourself the tough questions,
people,
you're going to get the answers you need.
You need to hear,
God dammit.
That smoothie is delicious.
So that's why.
Yes people.
So you know,
but I am a man and I am competitive.
So now I gotta tell you some fucking drinking and not even drinking stories.
I'm just going to rattle off some striking stats from earlier on in my career.
And this is no steroids by the way,
people,
okay.
This is pre steroids era in baseball.
And what a fucking joke,
by the way,
her
Goddamn a rod.
I don't care.
I don't get this shit.
The fucking 20 minute memory sports fans have.
Why were they doing the countdown to a rod 600th home run?
Can anybody explain that to me?
Oh,
you mean the Gal did roids and patted his fucking stats.
A monumental achievement.
Like Babe Ruth looked like he was in his second trimester is eating a fucking
hot dog at the plate and he banged out.
What,
713 is that what it is?
Dependent on RP 713 if I actually got that right,
that the level of,
of patheticness to my social life.
Um,
yeah,
I used have,
back in the day I could drink a 12 pack,
no fucking problem.
And then I'd go on to Mcdonald's.
I get a quarter pounder with cheese,
a cheeseburger,
you know,
large fry never liked it and nuggets.
Coca,
what else would I get?
I'd have to get maybe two cheeseburgers.
I needed a lot of bread in there,
fucking squirrel me.
And then I would,
you know,
go to bed and I would wake up literally three,
four hours later,
go to my job.
And other than being sleepy,
I felt fine and I would go down there,
I unload trucks,
you know,
kind of felt like ship.
And when the Roach coach showed up at 10 15 I'd go out there and maybe get a
slice of pizza,
you know,
just to kind of sop up the rest of the alcohol.
And I was good to go.
I was good to go.
But let me tell you something,
you do that for 20 fucking years.
It catches up with you,
catches up with you.
So one day you're 42 you have a couple of fucking whiskeys,
you know,
a couple of middle highlights and you're banged up the next morning.
And I'm not gonna apologize.
Okay?
There's too many people in this country that are obsessed with the youth
culture.
Now,
Jane,
when people say that,
you know,
says that old people,
because they're not fuckable anymore and they can't emotionally come to terms
with it.
We are a youth obsessed culture.
Tell me another,
and then they always got to bring up Japan.
How they respect their elders,
you know,
really,
how much do they respect them?
Are they,
are they walking up to them at a fucking single's bar?
You know,
I've always been turned on by 80 year olds.
You know your wisdom.
You're a fucking chicken neck.
Yeah,
I got to understand.
I'm like Brett Farve.
Okay.
Every time people think I'm going to fucking retire,
I come back for another goddamn round.
No,
maybe if I took the roids that guy's taken.
I could actually fucking drink the way I used to.
You know,
I'm actually in a debate,
a debate with a buddy of mine.
I think he did.
He took something for last season.
That guy was on the jets.
Okay.
He looked,
he looked like Neil O'Donnell.
Okay.
And then all of a sudden he has air quotes off season surgery and this guy
fucking comes back.
And
when he was like 39,
he looked like fucking George Blanda.
Then he comes back at 40,
and all of a sudden he looks like that kid who took his helmet off and the
Superbowl was it [inaudible] 97 I blocked it out.
And you don't ever tell you guys I was at that super bowl.
I was at that super bowl and Brett Farve took his helmet off and ran down the
street like a Douche.
Huh?
That's back when,
you know,
I think he's the reason why you're not allowed to do that anymore.
Right in the middle of the Superbowl.
He takes his fucking helmet off in,
runs down the fucking field,
you know,
with an earpiece in his agent going,
yeah.
Now smile real big and yell Wheaties,
you know,
to fucking sad moment in sports.
Do you guys watch any of that hall of fame game,
by the way?
Um,
what was it?
The fucking,
the cowboys versus the Goddamn Bengals.
How awkward was it watching a tio in Ochoco Sinco when he goes,
uh,
on Batman and then the other dudes like,
and I'm Robin.
All right,
so you're his ward
mean,
haven't they long talked about the gay relationship between Batman and Robin
does fucking teenager who's have no relation to uh,
Adam West,
whatever his fucking name is.
Am I really going to do that hacky bit?
I think I got to start boozing again.
I give this podcast a half a fucking thumb down.
All right,
let's get into this shit here.
Um,
so when he was,
I was down in uh,
sandy off.
Fuck.
All right.
Start off,
Bill.
Regroup.
You actually have some information.
You know what?
I got jury duty,
so I need you guys' help.
Okay.
This is a free damn podcast and I would appreciate a little bit of fucking
reciprocation.
How the fuck do I get out of this shit?
You know,
I was thinking of memorizing the Mel Gibson tapes and just go
and just when they say my name,
I'm just gonna start reciting some of his dialogue.
William Byrd,
I'm just going to go sit in there with your pussy hanging out the back of your
dress.
Look,
we all know the line.
I all you not line I need to mutter is,
is that the over the top racist one?
And I will never get jury duty again,
but uh,
there's gotta be a better way.
Okay.
There has to be a better way.
Is there a race of people out there left that you can sort of go off on where
you can come off as racist but it doesn't hold the same weight?
You know,
I mean,
I think the Yankees and red sox of race or blacks and Jewish people,
you know,
you trash either one of them,
your career is fucked,
but then you know,
you've got the middle of now the level ones,
you know,
like the twins,
if you go off on Italian people,
I do it all the time.
Oh look at my phone can take top.
Oh,
nobody gives a shit.
Jersey shore is an entire show making fun of Italian fucking people tell you
fucking juice heads and all this shit and half of those costs in that show,
they're not even Italian.
You know what I mean?
Could you do that with blacks?
That Jewish people?
You could not.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's why they're the upper.
That's why the here are the tier one are the Yankees or red sox.
Alright.
If you want to destroy your career,
say some shit about either one of those groups,
the shit is over.
All right?
You want to dip your toe into a little bit of racism.
I'd go with the Italians,
Irish people,
you can go off on Polish.
You know,
cause that sort of comes into way.
Uh,
now you just sort of making fun of white people in more of a specific sort of
way.
But uh,
you know,
and no one really knows what the fuck bad shit happen to any of us.
Whatever.
What a bad ever happened to with Italians.
You know,
they got gorgeous women,
you know,
some of them a little hairy and we'll give you that.
You know,
especially in the tramp stamp area.
Never seen that.
Ever see a girl with little little extra hair there and you're like,
Jesus,
your old g Geesh.
You know,
just thinking of what that Goddamn fucking,
who has going to look like.
It's going to look like decided George Michael's face and about fucking 1987.
So you look at this going off on Italian women,
I'm not even nervous,
I'm not worried about it.
And then you move on to,
I'll tell you know who's moved up in the rankings,
sort of like a Texas tech that turned its program around there with some genius,
new coach was Asians.
When I started in stand up comedy,
you could do a half hour on Asians and nobody gave a shit.
She's fucking going off going off on agents and then somewhere along the line
they will like a,
wait a minute,
didn't we teach you guys martial arts?
You know when did the master,
because I mean the student become the dose and start yelling at us.
So then they turned around and I think they've leap frog past the fuck you,
it was a problem with fucking Italian people is if I can be so bold,
they should pussies are hanging now is um,
the bad shit that you guys do.
I don't even know if it's cool,
but it's been so fucking glamorized that,
you know,
I mean,
look at good fellas,
at least the beginning of good fellas.
I love that.
I hate when the second fucking,
uh,
Henry becomes a rat,
you know.
I know I've talked about that before.
You know,
that fucking asshole actually has the balls to come out in public now and he
signed shit,
I want to go there.
And you know,
and p I if people like equate that guy with Ray Liotta is character.
This guy was,
was he fucking ran everybody out at one and after he did exactly what they told
them not to do,
he got himself into that fucking situation.
Granted,
if the movie is exactly how it went down a real life,
so why would you go down there and get,
get the uh,
get the autograph as somebody who told on his friends.
I'm asking you.
So anyways,
what I'm saying is,
uh,
yeah,
is much as Italians or Ricoh or acquainted with fucking organized crime.
I think people look at it the way you look at the beginning of,
um,
of good fellas when they're all hanging out in front of the coffee shop,
breaking balls,
they got on nice suits.
They got the cars,
they got the women,
they're not taking any shit,
you know,
it's like fucking Walker,
Texas ranger without,
I mean it was even like Walker,
Texas ranger was annoying because he's such a fucking do good are all the time.
It's on the right side of the law,
wears a condom.
He's annoying those guys.
They don't give a shit.
Joe Pesci,
you know,
sitting there having a fucking business conversation and he pushes that girl's
head down onto his dick.
Who doesn't want to do that?
Let's talk about racism this week.
People.
Out of all the stereotypes,
I would have to say that Italians,
they have some of the best stereotypes out there.
Irish,
what did we got?
Pasty phase.
Drunks,
potato,
Wheaton.
Shitheads I'm half,
I'm mostly German and then I'm,
I'm Irish.
So basically what do you fucking Nazi.
I got that.
And uh,
and then everybody else is just a fucking booze bag.
Going to church every week.
A and having like 18 kids.
All right.
What if,
okay,
so now we got to go all the way down to the cellar here,
the fucking Kansas city royals.
And I'm not equating this to who the people are.
I'm just saying as far as a standup comedian,
like the,
the team,
you can just fucking,
you know,
you can just score seven runs on them and there's nothing they can fucking do.
Um,
I don't really know if that exists now the way it's so politically correct,
native Americans just because of the odds of one of them actually being off the
reservation and in the crowd is,
hey,
you know what,
so many,
uh,
um,
sent me an email this week and uh,
this is just a great fucking email and it's just classic,
just shows how full of Shit I am is,
I'm,
I always compared like the Yankees and the red sox to what they're doing to
like,
you know,
a Walmart or like a best buy.
Um,
and evidently this guy sent me an email and of course I didn't do the research,
but one of the higher ups at one of the owners of Walmart actually owns the
Kansas city royals.
So he was basically saying that if that guy wanted to win is bad as the Yankees
and the Red Sox,
um,
do that actually they,
they would say rooting for Kansas City is like rooting for Walmart or something
like that.
And,
uh,
I think there might be simple validity in that point.
Um,
I mean,
God knows I can't back it up because I didn't read about it.
So,
uh,
once again,
I am exposed to how full of Shit I am,
but there's a passion in my full of shitness.
All right.
I feel like this is fucking winding down again.
Let's go to,
let's go to the board here.
Um,
last week I discussed,
uh,
clapping in the airport for veterans when they get off the plane.
You know,
that point they walk by and everybody's just like,
whew,
you know,
good game,
good gay.
Uh,
and it was one of those,
you know,
one of those weird things where it's like,
it just felt I didn't clap cause it just felt weird and it was like,
and,
and I'm sitting there feeling guilty why I want to show this guy.
I appreciate the fact,
you know,
that he went over there and everything,
but it's like,
I don't want to watch,
I know clapping isn't it?
So we actually had a couple of veterans chimed in here,
um,
or people in active service.
Okay,
here's what they have to say.
All right.
Listening to the late,
your,
uh,
your latest
podcast.
Yes.
It was a little weird getting off the plane in Atlanta,
coming back from 13 months in Iraq and having strangers clap as I was going up
the escalator.
Uh,
that being said,
I couldn't keep the rye smile off my foot,
my face,
I guess it's better than nothing.
Or the Vietnam scenario that you,
uh,
that you described.
Um,
so I wrote the guy back,
so I was saying clapping is okay.
And he said,
uh,
he goes,
yeah,
absolutely.
Again,
it's weird leaving that militarized environment and trying to
readjust to stepping foot in America.
So it's a little weird to have people actually happy to see you,
let alone clapping a random hugs and kisses.
Not so much unless they're from,
oh Jesus,
I'm the worst.
I can't read it unless they're hot and then all bets are off of course.
Uh,
all right.
So that's that guy's opinion.
Um,
oh.
Did have a guy shake my hand and thank me for this time.
I,
uh,
time in the service guy looked like he could have been a Vietnam vet,
so it wasn't a patronizing 20 year old douchebag handshake or a 50 year old
cubicle farm,
farm secretary.
A guy looked like he might've actually meant it and understood what the term
service meant.
I'm sorry,
I don't have the light on in my bedroom on.
I bring this over to the fucking window here.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
This really was supposed to be interesting and the way I read it,
that sounded like I was fucking reading and spelling test.
All right,
here's another guy.
Charming again.
Um,
I served in the Marines as a radio operator.
One of the guys in the,
one of those guys in the war movies with the backpack radios that invariably
invariably die within 30 minutes of the opening credits.
Uh,
my unit participated in the evasion and returned to Camp Pendleton,
California via a stopover in Baltimore.
As we came into the main terminal,
we received the awkward standing ovation.
Uh,
if I had had one of those cyanide pills,
the spy pilots carry between the cheek and gum,
I might've gone for it.
There has to be a happy medium between spitting and being an ass.
I know you're clapping so you can tell you,
tell your friends that you support the troops.
Just knock it off.
I know you really don't care.
We don't care that you don't care and we'll all be better off if you don't.
What does it say on
athletically clap or something like that?
Like it's the end of topcon.
Uh,
what's more is that every guy in the world internalizes other guys,
military service and wants to tell you about how he almost joined.
But a promising job in the food industry called.
So these clowns not only make your,
your walkthrough,
the term terminal,
super awkward,
but then they follow you into the bar and ruin your first experience around
women in eight months.
See,
that's what I felt like it was.
I mean,
what are they supposed to do?
Smile and wave.
Thank you.
14 confirmed kills,
right air.
I made the altar all star team.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
It's fucking weird.
So I don't know.
One guy says he doesn't mind it.
Uh,
I dunno.
This is how I do it.
If I'm in a bar and I see people in uniform,
I'll send out around a drinks.
I don't even walk up to him sent down.
They look all them,
you know,
I give them the,
uh,
more black people used to do when they're there.
When the,
the height of the,
the,
the fucking a salad.
I remember that Shit.
Anybody else used to watch fat Albert back in the day.
It's not like the full on 1968 Olympics or that stupid puff daddy advertisement
in Times Square.
It's not like that.
You know?
I love that one.
That puffy has in there like he's fighting the power in the fashion industry for
is Sean John Close.
He's fighting the power.
Everybody,
those goddamn eight year olds who sewed together as track suits,
they keep propelling.
They keep rebelling,
you know,
but he stay in strong.
Oh,
it must be great to always get to play the victim.
God Damn.
And I'm jealous.
I'm really fucking jealous of that.
All right,
so there you go.
I Dunno,
we got one for one against.
So it's a tie.
So I need more veterans to chime in here.
Yes.
On the clapping.
No,
on the clapping.
And this is the thing,
you can't just say yes in the clapping.
Why don't you come up with creative ways that people can thank you and I don't
care how filthy they are,
have fun with it for the love of God.
So I can actually maybe be funny on my own.
God Damn podcast and I actually have the nerve to get upset that fucking people
were trashing me on my own fucking alleged fan page.
I think I need another sip,
a smoothie so I can become even less funnier.
This really is anti funny juice.
You know,
you have a breakfast sandwich.
You fucking hilarious.
You breaking balls,
you flies down.
You don't even know it.
People laugh and with Yann at Ya.
Um,
so anyways,
let's get onto some youtube videos of the week.
Um,
I'll wait.
Did I talk about jury duty?
I did.
Didn't I did I guys,
how the fuck do I get out of jury duty?
I don't want to do it.
I've already done it.
I've done it.
Fucking,
I don't have any times I've done it.
I can only remember once,
but I'm gonna say three fucking times.
This is one of these weird things where as an American I want to do it.
It is my goddamn duty.
All right.
I would rather do community fucking service
then do jury duty.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
buddy.
You don't show up for that fucking shit.
He does.
Jack,
what you're going to get.
Does anybody know anybody who fucking blew off jury duty and actually got
arrested for it?
You know,
I figured California's a broke state so you know,
they,
they gotta be,
they gotta be like stretched pretty thin right now.
You know,
my problem is I fucking responded to it when I was living in New York and I
actually sat on a juror jury as an alternate juror and this dude,
they busted this dude trying to break in.
It was actually hilarious trying to pick a lock to break into a building and he
was trying to say that he was taking a piss and one of the best part,
you know,
and that's why he was turned into the doorway.
And uh,
one of the funniest things was when the cop was testifying saying,
do you think there's any way that he was actually urinating?
And the dude was working on the deadbolt locks,
so his hands were basically up where his chest was.
So he goes,
well,
unless he was trying to pee in his own face with the longest dick ever.
No,
he wasn't trying to pee.
He said it much more,
uh,
a much more cleaner way.
But,
uh,
I sat there as an alternate juror and I felt bad.
I felt bad for the fucking guy.
You know,
I don't have it in me to send someone to jail for doing some shit that I've
done.
You know,
it's just fucking ridiculous.
What?
Cause I never got caught.
Now I can judge this guy.
I never tried to break into somebody's house,
but I did other things.
I had a couple failed attempts to steal cars.
This is this,
my attempts to steal cars,
I would check to see if the door was unlocked and if it was unlocked then I
would get in it.
And then I would look in the visor for keys.
And when that didn't happen,
I just got out because I had no skills.
You know,
you can go on youtube and learn how to hot wire a car and it's funny,
they show you how to hot wire a car all under the guise of in case you run out
of gas or case you lose your keys,
that's it.
Run out of gas at stupid in case you lose your keys and you're in the middle of
fucking nowhere and a you need to hot wire your car and uh,
you know,
you can actually fucking do it.
You know when you can drink a fucking,
juggle your own urine in the process,
they try to make it like that.
Like it's a survivalist thing and there's all these comments underneath it.
Hey,
thanks a lot man.
I just got that 68 Mustang I always wanted.
You know,
now who knows if they're joking or not,
but
I don't know.
So anyways,
how do I get out of it?
See,
this is why you want to have as many friends as possible.
This is,
this is a true belief that I have come to in my life.
You can not have enough friends who are cops.
You just can't.
All right.
And I don't give a fuck how much you hate authority.
You're going to loose.
All right?
You've seen those guys.
Those guys can accidentally or on purposely kill you and be like,
ah,
you know,
I,
I had a muscle spasm.
Sorry about that.
And they walk.
So you want these guys on your side,
there's a cop lives on your block.
Bake them a cake that works.
Two fold.
One,
you get on his good side and two,
if you do some bad shit,
if he doesn't recognize you,
he's too fat to catch you.
You know?
And maybe when he reaches down for his gun,
his degree is his fucking love handles,
you know,
are pushing the gun a little bit back around to the ass area and he can't pull
it out.
Is Old Service revolver?
Um,
no,
actually,
you know,
I know a couple of cops out here in La.
I know a couple back in uh,
New York and yeah,
when I have new DVDs that come out,
I fucking send them out.
Hey,
you go fellas.
Remember this face?
Remember this face for what?
I'm speeding around in my fucking hybrid.
I really am a Douche.
Um,
anyways,
it's fucking plow ahead.
I'd also make friends with the veterans on your street.
You know,
maybe they actually smuggled back a grenade or some shit and you'll be privy to
see what it looks like when he fucking throws it at somebody on a 4th of July.
Just for the fuck of it.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah.
Okay.
So those are my two questions this week.
Veterans,
I want you to chime in,
okay?
Cause it's a tie right now.
All right?
Um,
about how people are supposed to show appreciation.
Okay?
So one guy says he doesn't mind the clapping,
but both of you said it was awkward.
The other person said he wanted to take a fucking cyanide pill.
All right?
So we're all over the map here.
And if you can come up with a creative way that a legal or not legal way that
people can thank veterans as they get off the plane,
please let me know.
And uh,
actually,
uh,
what do you think of mine?
You send down around a drinks and then you don't go down there and have the
fucking awkward conversation with them.
You know,
like,
what am I going to say to you?
I never went to war,
you know,
just start fucking doing quotes from platoon.
All right,
let's fucking plow ahead here.
Um,
youtube videos of the work of the week,
of the work of the week.
Uh,
youtube videos.
All right,
guy searched.
This guy walks into traffic,
gets hit.
This guy is such a fucking moron.
I actually thought that this was fake because I don't know how he doesn't see
this.
He walks into traffic doing a silly dance and I swear to God,
I believe he gets hit by an ice cream truck.
And I'll tell you right now,
if that doesn't put a smile on your face,
you're not American.
You're not American.
You're a fucking commie.
Pinko son of a bitch.
Do you know in Russia the ice cream trucks are gray?
Slate Gray.
They don't even have a picture of the ice cream on the side of it and they don't
play a fucking happy little pedophile.
Jingle has a,
as they drive down the street,
they don't.
They just played the,
I am Russia.
I'd take a comb and then I brush Ya.
That's what they do.
Just something fucking like that,
you know,
except they sing it.
Um,
slayer goes to church.
I think I might have recommended this one before someone else did.
Um,
but it's,
it's just awesome.
Um,
next one.
Our best judge Judy ending ever best judge Judy ending ever.
And this actually made me watch some of those,
uh,
like I fucking hate judge Judy.
I Hate Judge Carol.
I hate all those mother fuckers.
Okay.
This one is some lady screaming at this guy going,
you know,
you don't come in here and disrespect this quite like that.
Disrespect what court?
It's a fucking TV show.
You're dumb cunt.
You're not a fucking judge.
I'm so sick of these fucking people who get TV shows about a job and they think
that,
that there's their fucking job now is still the job that they're showing.
No,
you're a TV star.
It's not a fucking court of law.
Even though it has the authority of a court of law.
How many courts do you know out there?
Okay.
That ceased to exist if they get bad ratings.
You know what I mean?
Actually left that comment on one of those fucking youtube video things,
man,
just fucking girl show boat.
There was show boat and slam it down the hammer screaming and yelling and then,
you know,
they go to the commercial and the producer comes up and whispers in their ear
like,
yeah,
that was great television.
That was great.
Tell them,
hey,
do more yelling,
yell more.
ESPN is making a killing with the yelling
I fuck out.
Maybe it's my hatred of women.
I don't know what it is,
but those fucking women judges,
that's my nightmare of what being married is.
You know,
cause you're legally bound to them and they can take half your shit.
So now they can fucking yell at you like that.
Banging a hammer hammer on some fucking coffee table.
Oh,
I'll tell you right now.
You can take half my shit.
I'll fucking walk just to get away from you and your fucking goddamn
menopause.
Chicken neck.
Fucking screaming at me.
Go fuck yourself,
Judge Judy.
There's no fucking way I would stand there.
Okay.
And get yelled at like that because a third of my swing set is on my neighbor's
property.
You're gonna fucking yell at me like that.
Cause cause why?
Why are you yelling at me like that?
You don't even feel it,
Judge Judy.
All your,
Oh,
you want to do is get good ratings.
You're fucking grand standing.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Please tell me you're not naked under that robe.
You amazed created old whore.
Sorry,
I don't like those fucking shows.
That's the same thing with like that Donald Trump.
If you actually think Donald Trump is rich and you're a fucking idiot,
you're a goddamn idiot.
He needs that job to keep his,
his face out there.
What do they call it?
Your Q rating?
Is that what they say in the business?
How recognizable you fucking faces.
Go Down to Atlantic city and talked to a couple of people about Donald Trump and
his fucking,
he,
you know,
he is,
he is rich,
but he's like,
you know,
he's the rich version of that guy who lives on your street who has like four old
cars and different,
uh,
levels of restoration and a fucking old refrigerator just rusting out on his
front property.
That guy,
the guy who makes your fucking property value go down.
He does that at like the skyscraper level.
I'm not saying he doesn't have more money than Uri,
but you know what I mean enough already.
If she really had all these successful businesses going on,
you don't have time to see if Ozzy's wife is better than Cindy.
Lopper do you?
I don't think you do.
All right,
last week on the podcast,
um,
I read some hate mail from single mothers,
uh,
who got mad at me when I was talking about stay at home moms with husbands who
give them money.
And uh,
I actually got some shit from,
uh,
from actual stay at home moms.
So,
uh,
one person chimed in on that actually brought up a decent point that was
delivered in a very extreme way,
which is how we do it on this podcast.
But I think there's,
there's,
there's a little bit of point here,
said,
I just listened to the August 2nd podcast.
He says,
isn't it funny how martyred the women who choose to bank some loser,
he's talking about single mothers here who they probably bitch at incessantly.
This guy sounds like he's going through a divorce.
Um,
and they end up single parent.
Wait a minute.
I really can't read this week.
People.
It's the lack of alcohol in my system.
All right,
let's start over again.
Bill,
isn't it funny how martyred the women who choose to bank some loser and end up a
single parent like to make themselves and in his quads?
I am a single mom.
I do it all by myself.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
And the guy goes on to say,
who told you to get knocked up before you got an education?
It's a great fucking point.
Who told you to let some loser who won't even stick around.
Oops.
Stick it in you.
When you know what is going to come of it.
You got loaded.
Found some hardy loser who works a part time construction job.
Hang on,
let me keep scrolling down and let them knock you up.
You chose the loser.
You didn't do birth control.
You didn't wait too.
You had your education or your career going and we need to celebrate you for
being the poor,
pitiful victim.
You are.
Cry me a river conc I have no more sympathy for you than the people who complain
about having no money but never run out of beer,
cigarettes or lottery tickets and our sporting a pony keg for a gut from all the
over eating they do.
There you go.
People,
that is the extreme opinion of the week.
We might've had a,
a new segment there.
Now,
obviously,
um,
what makes that thing funny is it is,
it is so extreme,
but he's also,
you know,
he's ignoring the fact that there's a,
there's different levels of information that is passed on to people at different
levels of,
uh,
ah,
you know,
look at super rich people have access to all the fucking information need and
even their kids can get fucking knocked up.
But you know what I mean as if you really look at the educational system in the
inner city schools in that type of shit.
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
it's fucking horrific what goes on in there.
And it's absolutely pathetic.
The,
I don't know that,
that,
that people in general don't give a shit that the more poor you are,
the worst,
the fucking free education that you're supposed to get.
His,
so I mean,
I,
I do great it a little bit on a,
on a,
uh,
what do they call that?
What was that shit when you a scale grading scan of fucking remember I'm a
moron.
I don't know.
I grew up in the suburbs.
So I had a,
I had a decent education and I remember when I started working in a warehouse
and I started working with these other kids from a Brockton and,
uh,
the education that they got was a way more street education than they got like a
,
you know,
the x's and o's from school,
and a lot of them had fucking kids real young,
just like their parents did.
And for all you fucking people out there who were picture and blacks and Puerto
Ricans,
these kids were white.
They were white,
but they were listening to that hip hop.
No,
I'm fucking around.
seriously.
So,
but that,
there is,
there is like a,
uh,
there,
there is a great point in there where it's like you weren't born a single mom.
You know what I mean?
Like if somebody is handicapped,
I'd never make some fun of somebody fucking handicapped.
Okay.
I wouldn't,
all right.
It's just,
you know,
it was an accident or you were born that way,
but you weren't born pregnant.
I don't know.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's really hard for me from where I came from to imagine why someone would want
to be.
There's actually people out there who want to have a kid at 16.
MMM.
I guess a lot of it comes down if their parents did it.
I have no fucking idea.
MMM.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
But yeah.
Okay.
Any single moms out there?
I mean,
do you,
is there any sort of responsibility on yourself?
Do you ever sit down and just be like,
wow,
I,
you know,
no pun intended,
really fucked myself over here,
you know,
I dunno,
I'm of that opinion that that's how you grow in life.
Okay.
You know,
you can't blame other peoples for your failure.
Like Peyton manning does every goddamn Sunday he loses.
We had protection issues.
Okay.
Oh,
that actually works.
Ah,
that's what these single moms should do.
They should come out just like at the end of one of those Peyton manning fucking
bad games.
He has come out with a towel around your neck and just,
and I,
we are protection issues.
Um,
I don't know if there was a hole in the condom.
Oh wait,
he didn't even wear one.
Um,
it was because look,
he had a condom on initially and then he went and he put it in my ass and he
wanted to go back to my vagina.
I made him take it off because,
you know,
I,
I didn't want to get an infection so I didn't get infected for anybody wandering
.
But now I have a child and you have no idea how difficult it is to try to raise
this child.
I know it has to be unbelievably fucking difficult,
but at the end of the day,
you're the one who laid on your back and took a hot one.
Okay.
So for all you ladies,
all the booties out there,
um,
yeah,
don't do that.
This is what you want.
You want to get married first,
so you're legally bound to that son of a bitch.
So when he knocks you up and then leaves like the piece of fucking garbage that
he is,
he's going to owe you money.
You know?
And I know what you're saying,
but what some of these guys,
they just blow it off.
They become dead beat dads.
They'd rather go to fucking jail and he was,
then you married a fucking loser.
Okay.
Do you understand that you're married a fucking loser?
And I think this day and age,
women have no business complaining about a what?
They make an hour.
Okay?
Cause if you listen to the beyond say catalog of music that she's put up,
if you could sit through that hours and hours of shit that she has put out,
evidently,
um,
you guys,
your booty licious you're independent women and a,
if you like it,
you got to put a ring on it.
I mean,
right there is the trilogy.
That's all the information you need
to get ahead in life.
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
Look,
you know,
I'm trying to be,
uh,
not devil's,
I'm to be mediated here.
I understand that a shit happens.
I mean,
who out there in their fucking career never had a girl who was late,
never took a chance.
You know,
we all have,
so this guy is wrong for judging them that harshly,
but these single moms to 100%
paint themselves as these fucking victims.
You're not all right.
You know,
God damn well,
it's not easy to raise a kid.
I did.
He not fucking know that I knew that it's 16.
That was the horror,
the fucking horror when I was 16 to get somebody fucking knocked up,
you know?
And I was so fucking nervous about knocking somebody up.
I didn't get laid till I was 19.
That's the only reason I could get laid at 14.
Me coming down the fucking hall with my orange hair and my freckles,
I was beaten.
The ladies off me,
he was like,
listen ladies,
I'd love to have a threesome in the seventh grade.
Okay,
I get it.
You know,
I'm like that White Rhino,
um,
rare.
I'm desirable.
Like the hope diamond.
That was pathetic.
I mean,
then 19 I started my fucking bang and career and um,
I'm so full of Shit.
All I would do is just make sure the girl was on the pill.
This is back when we thought I aids you could only get if you are gay or if you
were a trucker
and um,
you know,
I'm completely full of Shit.
I think if I was a fucking woman,
I probably have six kids by now.
All right,
there you go.
We need veterans and we need single moms to fucking chime in here.
Do you think that guy's being too harsh?
Obviously.
Obviously he's a little harsh.
All right.
Um,
oh,
here's this thing I wanted to read about the royals.
I actually saved this here.
If I can go back for a second.
I,
Bill,
I've heard you many times talk about how the Red Sox and Yankees are ruining
baseball with how many stars they're able to buy.
Unlike other teams.
I agree with you to a certain extent.
I think there should be a salary cap to make it more fair for everyone in the
league.
However,
here is a fun fact.
The owner of the royals is a recent CEO of Walmart.
The royals are one of the few teams.
Hang on here.
One of the few teams used as an example of how teams without enough money can't
compete yet,
their owner is a multibillionaire dude.
That guy's not a mall.
You're not as CEO of Walmart in your own multi billionaire,
I bet is a CEO.
He probably makes some disgusting amount,
like 10 million a year.
Um,
one,
I don't know if I agree with this,
you're acting as if Walmart owns the royals.
It's a c o of Walmart.
Can we find out how much those guys make?
Hasn't one of them written a book like the secret to success?
He sits there in his fucking seersucker suit with his hand on his fuck head in
his hand.
And that,
that,
you know,
that smile that Jay Leno smile where you don't show your teeth,
that's supposed to be like the relaxed.
It's easy.
I mean,
he's going,
he interviewed them many in,
in and he talked to the guy who plays the trumpet.
Um,
how teams can compete with the nonverbal,
but yeah,
it's not about how much money the team has,
it's about how much the owners are willing to invest on the team.
No,
it is about how much it is about how much money you have.
You don't have enough money to invest into the fucking team.
Listen to this sentence.
It's not about how much money the team has,
it's about how much the owners are willing to invest.
So I guess he's making the leap now that because this guy is a CEO for Walmart,
that he's now a multibillionaire.
God Damn it.
I love when I list,
when I find out my listeners that just as dumb as I am,
he's not a multibillionaire.
Walmart itself takes in billions of dollars every year.
And I know that because I've never looked it up.
Okay.
But they don't pay a CEO multimillions of dollars.
I bet the Walmart family,
the upper echelon,
the JP Morgans,
the incestuous family that continues to fuck each other.
So the money stays in their family.
Allah,
the fucking Rothchild family.
Right.
That's how you end up with a kid in the attic.
You know what I'm saying
though,
yet?
Cause I don't know what I'm saying.
All right.
So anyways,
he says the Walmart guy doesn't give a fuck about baseball.
So he doesn't risk the money on his puttsy.
This is why I love being in bars.
This is what this guy's doing right now.
He just assumed that because the CEO of Walmart is one of the owners of Kansas,
the Kansas city royals,
that that guy is a multi fucking billionaire.
And then with that knowledge that he just pulled out of his ass,
he's now going to complete the fucking dismount with this statement.
The Walmart guy doesn't give a fuck about baseball,
so he doesn't risk his money on his team.
Yeah,
he doesn't give a fuck about baseball.
He just bought a Goddamn team.
Um,
if he had the passion of Steinbrenner,
we would be talking about how the royals and Yankees are ruining baseball is
heat now.
That right there,
if you don't know what my podcast is about,
it's that email right there.
What you do is you start off with a piece of information that actually is a fact
and then you just run with it.
You know,
if we were smart on this podcast,
what we would do is you'd be like,
Oh wow,
that guy's a CEO at Walmart.
Well let's find out how much he makes a year.
Does he own it by himself?
You know,
let's find out what it takes to run a fucking baseball team.
I mean,
you completely ignored the fact that Kansas City is not a major media market.
That's another way that a,
the red sox and Yankees make a ton of cash with the yes network and Nelson.
I mean,
how many people even live in Kansas City?
Huh?
With your fucking rib shacks out there.
Um,
I,
I do know what you're saying because I know people in Pittsburgh,
they went through the roof when they found out that the pirates were one of the
most profitable teams in the league because a,
they don't spend shit on the team and then they get all that welfare money from
the Red Sox,
Yankees and whoever else goes over the fucking salary cap.
Um,
so there is an element of truth in that shit.
But,
uh,
I'll tell,
you know,
my favorite baseball team is right now.
I mean,
I always root for the Red Sox,
but I fucking love the devil rays.
The devil rays remind me of like the Orioles in the 70s you know what I mean?
Where they just were a fucking,
just an unbelievable franchisee.
Oreos in the 70s I swear to God they,
the,
the level of pitchers that they just one after another,
I don't know how they ended up getting him a Frank Tenana,
Jim Palmer,
they just always had these,
these potentials.
Cy Young winning,
I'm
winning pitchers and then like they're fucking third baseman in short,
short for like almost 30 years.
They were bringing up a fucking hall of Famer.
They like Frank Robinson,
Brooks Robinson,
cal Ripkin jr from the sixties seventies into the 80s I guess frank and Brooke
retired.
There was a little bit of a gap there.
Who the fuck paid poo play third base
for the Orioles in the 79 world series?
Uh,
going back too far of I first thought thought I had was Doug to
Sensei Bobby gritch.
Those are like angels,
I believe.
California angels,
Rod Carew.
Why am I thinking of those guys?
You know,
it's funny,
as I can remember,
all of the fucking pirates from the,
I guess cause they won.
Okay.
Eddie Murray played first base.
Willie Stargell played first base for the pirates.
Lily,
I can go right around the unfilled.
Tim Foley was second base.
I can,
I can only do half the fucking ed art.
Omar Marino,
Dave Parker,
John Candaleria,
Kent to Colby.
How come I can't remember you?
The fucking Orioles.
Remember that guy?
You remember that guy in the Orioles?
Maybe you can find this picture on the m podcast.
There was a guy in the Orioles who broke his jaw and through the whole world
series he had half a football helmet.
Literally like the gray face mask.
I can't remember his fucking name either.
It gives a shit.
All I'm saying is the fucking that the devil rays in my Goddamn team,
I think that they're,
they're the shit.
They don't have a lot of money.
They got a low payroll and they just have the best prospects in the league and
they're doing it the old school way.
I got nothing but respect for him.
And I'm slowly getting back into baseball.
Most of you know,
when,
uh,
David Ortiz tested positive for some shit.
I just,
I had a tap out,
you know what I mean?
That was like finding out lone ranger,
a transvestite.
It's just,
yeah,
there's too much information.
I don't want to know that.
Okay.
It's one of my heroes and it just,
you know,
part of me died that day,
so,
but I'm gradually coming back and I'm coming back because of teams like the
devil rays.
I just want those teams to fucking knock off the bigger teams.
I don't give a fuck.
What are you gonna Chat?
2007 at me.
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
Hey,
Ron hits his 600th,
whole broad.
Hey,
you mean the guy took steroids and had a good 400 of those fucking home runs on
roids.
That guy,
the guy who came back who,
who's allegedly clean,
but he's just as big as he was when he was on roids.
Is any doctors out there?
Can anybody for the love of God explained to me how the fuck you do roids get
off a roids and you come back and you just as fucking big.
I think that means you're Rhonda,
then you're onto the next shit.
Although somebody I know who's really into baseball,
uh,
stats was telling me that when,
when he was on the shit,
he was hitting a home run like every fucking 14 at bats.
And then,
uh,
he got off the shit and then it went to like 18 at bats and now it's down to
like two every 23 at bats.
So maybe he's not on the shit.
I don't fucking know
why.
Why am I just openly trashing people with no information?
Cause that's what this fucking podcast is about.
All right?
A few weeks ago I talked about how I,
uh,
or maybe it was last week,
how I was really into breaking bad and that made everybody want to come out here
and start telling me what their favorite TV shows are.
So here are some of you guys can check out.
This is one I didn't even know exist existed.
Uh,
moral Orel
and that was like a claymation show.
Is that what it was?
And it was on adult swim and he got canceled but it really attached religion I
guess.
Then I watched a little bit of it.
It was so fucking depressing.
I don't know if I can watch it.
I have to watch it now.
I guess it's just available on DVD.
Go on Youtube and check out a couple of clips.
There's one where the fucking father is walking around and it's a first person
shoot.
Um,
for those of you play video games or watch porno,
um,
it's in the first person and he just keeps looking down at this whiskey glass
and it keeps drinking at any hears his wife talking to their child behind closed
doors and the kids going,
why does daddy drink?
I don't like it when he drinks and she's just going,
oh,
you got to understand he's just a different person.
When he drinks it's okay.
And she's giggling and laughing like he has no drinking problem.
Then she walks out into the hall,
does not see the father,
and she breaks down crying for like 20 seconds.
It's fucking brutal.
And then she looks up and sees him who the whole time,
by the way,
keeps taking sips of his whiskey.
When she finally sees him,
she immediately stopped crying,
shuts down all of her emotion and walks the other way down the hallway.
It's fucking,
and I have to watch it.
All right.
Here's some other ones.
People recommended true blood.
I don't know what that is.
Psych and somebody recommended on her entourage.
Evidently they still haven't picked up the fact that it always ends the same
way.
There's a problem and then they all get on a jet and go to Vegas and it all
works out.
Um,
underrated.
Overrated for this week.
Um,
overrated.
The dollar menu at fast food joints,
underrated,
illegal immigrants,
uh,
person did not give an explanation on either one of those.
And I'm going to actually chime in.
Um,
overrated is because I was in a touristy place down in San Diego,
La Jolla.
Um,
overrated would be,
uh,
any breakfast place that you have to fucking stand in line for.
You know,
that's the one that the chick using.
All right.
I got another fucking a underrated for you.
Underrated a fucking device.
That light that lets you know the batteries are going to wear out.
Sorry about that.
I was right in the middle of the underrated overrated in my fucking Olympus ls
10.
Just fucking conked out on me.
Sorry about that.
I was saying,
let me continue here.
Let me just give you guys a breather.
She can figure out what the fuck just happened.
Because the way I'm going to edit this thing,
I know it's,
it's just going to be really choppy.
Basically.
Uh,
my battery's ran out so I was in the middle of the underrated,
any of those fucking breakfast places that have the long lines at him cause they
have the best,
it's fucking eggs.
It's never worth the long line.
Okay.
I'm not saying to go to some shit place that has rubber eggs,
but there,
there's a,
there's another place close by,
you know,
and every time you go to those places with the long lines,
it's usually for the chicks because they,
they're just addicted to sugar and they want to go in and get the fucking
stuffed French toast with the cheese cream cheese and the fucking ice cream on
top.
Fuck all of that.
All right,
you're a goddamn man.
Go get bacon and eggs at a fucking diner and get on with your morning.
Um,
and uh,
underrated,
I would say is a surfing.
I was down there.
I am absolutely in San Diego,
absolutely fucking terrified of,
uh,
the ocean.
And I watched these guys surf.
I had my little flip camera there cause I was hoping someone was going to get
eaten by a shark or at the very least attacked.
And I could have this fucking awesome video of this guy getting eaten by a
shark.
And then he'd stick my head in and be like,
I'm going to be at the Hampton Beach Casino this fucking Thursday.
You know,
the ultimate fucking promo video,
I guess Friday I'm going to be there,
you know?
But um,
yeah,
I actually,
I came real close.
I was going to actually do a,
I was going to take a surfing class when I was down there and become the world's
first redheaded surfer,
you know,
and if I actually dominated in that sport,
do you realize that redheads would fucking be dominating the surfing world from
fucking snowboarding all the way to fucking surfing?
And that would be it.
And when that ever happened,
you'd know that Jesus was coming.
Um,
all right,
that's the fucking podcast for this week.
Uh,
just to let you guys know this week,
on a Thursday,
August 12th,
I'm going to be at the,
uh,
Newport Yachting Center in Newport,
Rhode Island.
And on Friday the 13th,
I'm going to be at the Hampton ballroom casino and a Hampton Beach New
Hampshire.
Um,
please come out.
Uh,
these are big venues,
so bring as many friends as you possibly can.
Tickets are selling well.
So I want to tell everybody I really appreciate it.
All the support out there and a,
and next week I'm playing a brand new comedy club in Portland,
Oregon.
And I'm hoping there's a lot of you in Portland right now out there in Oregon
going,
Holy Shit,
I didn't even know.
I had no idea that there was a club out there.
Nor did I know that bill's coming out there where I'm letting you know I'm going
to be in Portland,
Oregon.
Um,
not this weekend,
the following weekend,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
So let's see.
This Thursday's to 12 so that would be the night when I just look at the fucking
calendar.
Why don't I just look at the fucking calendar?
Yeah.
The 19th,
20th and 21st I am going to be at the um,
yeah,
yeah.
At the fee at helium,
you know helium comedy club in Philly.
Well,
the same guy opened one out there in Portland,
Oregon.
Alright.
Helium Comedy Club.
I'm going to be out there on the 19th 20th and the 21st so for the love of God,
come on out,
check out the new digs.
I got a brand new hour and once again,
thanks to everybody who listens to the podcast and also please don't take the
podcast seriously.
All right.
There's always people doing that shit.
I got an email from somebody who came out to my show down in La Jolla and was
saying how he had to drag his wife to,
to my show because uh,
all her girlfriends was saying that I was misogynistic and anti fucking woman
women because a,
their husbands listened to my podcast and a,
you know,
I'm not anti women,
I just,
I,
I just trash them.
So why don't you lighten up fucking whores and come out to my shoe.
All right,
my house phone is ringing.
That's probably the landlord.
Where is the rent?
I will talk to you guys next week.
Everybody have a great week.
[inaudible] arguing with her dad and an actual death.
He caught a nasty virus and there was the ever present football player rapist.
They were all in love with Diane.
They were doing all,
they caught a bullet,
but it only hit his leg while it should have been a better shot and got him,
and they were all in love with guy and they were drinking from a fountain that
was born like an avalanche coming down the mountain.
[inaudible] a cheesy show
you on
[inaudible].